for a deeper look at this we're joined
by Gabriel DeBenedetti he's a national
political reporter at Politico good
morning welcome good morning as we
mentioned earlier in the week president
from said that attorney the Attorney
General was weak on on leaks so what do
you make of this press conference what
was the intended audience here was the
president the audience here or was it
was it a serious campaign to get back at
leak
well obviously the Attorney General is
quite serious about this new campaign
that he's launching against these leaks
but there's also no doubt that this
really was for an audience of one and
that's the President as you said that
there there have been lots of reports
about strains between the two sides so
it's clear here that attorney general
sessions is going out of his way to say
listen mr. president I'm hearing you I
promise we're on the same side here
now pay attention as I go after these
leaks there are also two different kinds
of leaks that we seem to be talking
about and the ones that the president
seems focused on are the ones that are
more about that the White House intrigue
going on versus classified information
doesn't that difference have to be
looked at when sessions is considering
these Lakers yeah absolutely and we
haven't gotten a lot of clarity yet into
what the various kinds of leaks are that
they'll be looking at this was more of a
broad there are leaks and we're going to
look at it which is a message that the
president will take pretty happily but
as you say there are a number of
different leaks here and some of them
have been fairly embarrassing to the
president what's not clear is how
actually damaging they've been to
national security right big change at
the White House this week new chief of
staff are things changing already well
there have been changes in some staff
and John Kelly the new chief of staff
does appear to be cracking down a little
bit on what access some folks in the
White House have did the president that
is the most immediate change that a lot
of people in the West Wing have noticed
that folks are not really able to just
walk in and get the president's ear but
it'll take a little bit longer before we
see if there are any real long-term
changes here in the short run yeah there
are some different people in different
positions but as we've seen in this
White House over the last eight months
that tends to happen fairly frequently a
lot of generals with authority and also
HR McMaster is one of them
his national security adviser got a vote
of confidence but it seemed to come a
little bit out of nowhere I think he
said gentlemen McMaster and I are
working very well together that from the
president why was this necessary for the
president
this has been something that has been
not really litigated in the mainstream
but in some conservative wings of the
media and in some places where the
president has real support the McMaster
has been under fire there have been
reports that he's been clashing behind
the scenes with some presidential
advisors such as Steve Bannon who has
supporters and a more naturalist wing of
the president's backing so a faction of
the conservatives right now at this
point that's exactly right as a faction
of these conservatives have accused
McMaster of not really trying to work
for the President's agenda so this was a
this was a attempt by the President to
say listen McMasters got my back I've
got his let's focus on some other things
here the Congress is often at August
break as has been widely reported they
they failed to repeal and replace
Obamacare they're talking about moving
on now is Obamacare a replacement for
Obamacare essentially dead at this point
what a lot of people who are in Capitol
Hill have done recently is quoted the TV
show Game of Thrones to me they say what
is dead may never die they're basically
saying listen it looks like the
Obamacare repeal effort is done for now
but we can never really count it out
this is clearly a top priority to a lot
of Republicans so it's not necessarily
going anywhere yet I don't know if when
you're quoting Game of Thrones it's
always a good thing
gave DeBenedetti thank you we appreciate
it thank you